[موسيقى]
منذ ان اطلقت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الحرب على الارهاب في عام 2001 شنت القوات
الجويه الامريكيه عشرات عمليات الاغتيال
التي استهدفت قاده تنظيمات ارهابيه في
القاعده وكذلك في داعش هذا كان عبر طائرات
مسيره لكن البطل الذي حضر دائما في اغلب
هذه العمليات كان صاروخ اجي ام 114 هل
فاير
[موسيقى]
صاروخ اي جي ام 114 هل فاير انتجته شركه
لوكيد مارتن في بدايته ودخل الخدمه عام
1984 كصاروخ مضاد للمدرعات لكن صغر حجم
الصاروخ وخفه وزنه جعله مثاليا لطائرات
المسيره مثل مسيرات ريبر وكذلك مسيرات
بريداتون
[موسيقى]
احدث اصدار للصاروخ كان من طراز هايل فاير
وهو من الاسلحه الامريكيه السريه الذي
يعرف باسم قنبله النينجا تم استبدال راس
الصاروخ الحربي الشديد الانفجار بسته
شفرات تنطلق من الصاروخ لتمزق الهدف الى
اشلاء دون الحاق اي اذى بمن حوله
[موسيقى]